こんにちははじめ社長です2皿も僅かな僕は同じで特に高ガットこれをしましたって
いう思いでは特にないでずっとスプレッドそれ日々は僕は吉田洗顔料するに解く年度に
もせませんでした
なんでもうねアイアン開学海にも入ったしプールもちょびっといったしあナビも見れた
しね
家から楽しい学生最後の夏休みが過ごせたんじゃないかなと思っています皆さんどう
でしたからですに実は大学の夏休みは9月者なので僕はもう少しお休みします
もう夏の終盤ということですね今日はかき氷を作ろうと思いますドンキ行ったよねあん
ぱんなんですしかなかった
そのっぽいのいや方が下がっもっと大人っぽい
が with lisa とかねコムサイズムとかねそういうかき氷機が欲しかった
何処にも行くありますねこう
これで賭け事実際作っていくわけなんですけども艶男にすげーな
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
よしできました薄めこれ打ち込むがいいだけどこれで交流作らなきゃいけないのかこれ
でこれをつくってここに打ち込んでもうこのパーティーホテルもで砂利て普通にあると
思ったかホンダですねこちら
僕的を準備しましたパターン3食べないようなかき氷を食べたいと思います墨汁
のめーる yahoo 知恵袋に僕ズーって飲んだら死にますか
60泣き顔やしてすと動物の皮から採れる三河からできているので体に
以外ではありません息子かゲージの時に牧場一方に落ちてしまいました
僕前の勇気なる会社に電話しましたら大丈夫ですよと言われました怖い w 大丈夫な
んかこれ危険だったらやりたくないああ大丈夫らしいですね体に害はないのかな
大学で書道
変更する人もなと言ってます成就の話ですと体に害はない
つかし墨汁は8飲み物ではないのでもう見つけ
ちょっとぐらいなら大丈夫ですよよって結論から言うと害はないらしいです
僕じゃあが言わないんだけどもうあくまであの文字を書くためのものなのでしょ今日で
はないということを理解してください
睦生
ました
のもいいからあんまり入れすぎるとれたかな水入れていきます
あまり動く羽化したくないんだこれちゃうからさ私は真っ黒です氷にしますまあたらの
交流はで作ってそれはアンパンマンにぶちこんジャポン年公明して作るんですよ
ブーブーいいじゃねーっつに行こうっ
めっちゃ
4日
なぜか触ると黒くなりますこれ大丈夫かな
もう
いけるチェルスこれお前はこれやばいよ世紀末だ街で
なうこうやればいいのかな大丈夫ねっ
でもバスケなんかおかしいってなんかおかしいって
まとまってないおかしいって3が飛ぶかしマジ勘弁どういうこと
何が起きているなになになになになに一般公募して来たタワーまずはシャッターなんて
ほとんどこのブログバス見知りしたまんまってまって第三者なんだけど
あっちたきたきたきましてきました
me
処罰でしょいやーいうじゃあ最初はなんかわけわかんないけどめっちゃすってきたん
ですけどなんか成功しました
こちらが墨汁で作ったかき氷でございますどうですかね
本土 dic て大丈夫かな書道家が先生今日上位ってくらいだから間違いはないと
思うんですよね介助技術は去っすぐずっと言って rapport ナースば問わず
死んだりしないよ
大丈夫だよ
書道家の先生が言ってたんだっております
もう良い美味しい
[音楽]
war
[拍手]
[音楽]
うんは安中で甘いとより風味下てるという感じですねと作るところ日本的な風に出る
とっても美味しい味なっておりました
もしあれ際は自己責任でよろしくお願いしますでは美味しいでぜひ皆様といいじゃない
と思いますじゃあなっ
ふっ